good morning believe nation today's
message is be restless over to you
robert zemeckis TV go you know all I
want to do is our good scripts mm-hmm
however they have to manifest themselves
have you ever had an agenda have you
ever been I never had a mindset I never
have I've never had like I am i'm too
Restless i I could never hears what I on
I don't know what I want to do but I
know what I don't want to do is that
what I can answer the question like that
I don't want to do the same type of
movie over and over again mm-hmm but I
wouldn't want to just be doing comedies
I wouldn't want to just be doing
suspense movies or action movies I would
I mean I would that I mean I always want
to like mix it up when i look at the
most successful people that I know and
the people that we profile on this
channel a common trait that you see is
that they are restless that they they
don't settle that they don't just keep
doing the same thing over and over and
over again there's always a discomfort
and that they want to learn more get
better do something new be creative do
something different and too many people
a lot of entrepreneurs start a business
and they have some success and they
started that business because they
didn't want to be in the box you know
they didn't want to work for the man but
then they create a box themselves and
they stopped innovating they stop
creating they start doing different
things and then they just get stuck and
they let those they let that success in
the past be changed to prevent them from
going forward and doing something new
and different I think in general growing
up we are restless right kids are
restless naturally we're just Restless
yeah I look at hayden you know seven
years old he will let me know when he's
not happy about something right he
doesn't had the filters you know this is
part of all of us naturally but I think
as we get older a lot of people just
they settled you know you're not happy
with something you're uncomfortable you
know you don't like the way something's
going but you just settle for it like
well that's the way the world is
and you accept mediocrity consistently
in your life and and it seems to kind of
get worse as you kind of even get older
and the weight of the world is on your
shoulders where the successful people
are the ones who accept responsibility
and they say I know I'm Restless I don't
like this I'm going to change something
right like if you are restless and
unhappy about something then you should
go and change it and you have the
ability to go and change it and you to
believe that you can go and change it
and not just blame other people right
and so if you are feeling that way you
feel like I need to grow I need to do
something new I have these creative
ideas and I like to go and execute on
them then find a way to get started even
on a small scale start and don't let the
restlessness hold you back a lot of
times people seem restless as something
that's dis comfortable with this
comfortable that'll work uncomfortable
right they see discomfort and so because
there's that pain they don't want to do
it right anything that's painful a lot
of times we try to avoid right we avoid
pain and go for pleasure so because
being restless is painful this
uncertainty it's not a great feeling
then we hold ourselves back and we do
the safe boring easy thing to do where
for me if I'm Restless if I'm unhappy
about something I get excited because I
know something bigger is coming because
the restlessness and unhappiness will
force me to change what I'm doing to
change my schedule to break out of the
box that I now have made for myself to
go off and do something else so the next
time you are feeling restless one take
accountability for your world you can
change it you can go and do something
you can make it better don't blame
anybody else and to get excited lean
into it feel the discomfort and know
that through that something great will
come so the question day today is what
are you currently restless about leaving
in the comments below I'm going to join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events vessel
more this prey so give me go